[Music]
nigeria has a cash problem
i mean it's the richest country in
africa with a nominal gdp of over 400
billion dollars
but when it comes to making transactions
most locals pay with cash
in fact only about 35 percent of
nigerians even have a bank account
and with a population of over 200
million people
that's a lot of paper floating around
and
excess cash can lead to increased crime
corruption and a difficulty for some
nigerians to accrue credit
and obtain loans so a tech entrepreneur
named tayo oviosu
came up with an idea to change the way
nigerians think about money
which quickly set him on a path to
becoming one of the country's biggest
rising stars
of fintech
[Music]
i was born in lagos nigeria
in west africa
growing up here you know really was
fantastic for me
i learned a lot in terms of just grit
and
learning to handle a variety of issues
that you face every day
where not all the infrastructure works
smoothly
i was raised by a single parent my mom
um raised five kids and i was the last
of five boys
i got to see firsthand at a very young
age
how she was putting in so much to make
ends meet for
all of us and the sacrifices that she
was making
inspired by his mother's work ethic and
emphasis on education
oviosu moved to the united states for
his undergrad degree at the age of 16.
he majored in electrical engineering at
usc and later received a master's at
stanford's graduate school of business
while i was at stanford one of the
things that really
got questioned on is you know what
really matters to you right and why
what is it that you really want to do i
narrowed it down to
i want to help bring ideas to life first
and foremost on the african continent
but just generally speaking after
working for a few tech companies in
america
oviozu headed back to lagos on a search
to find an idea he could bring to life
and it didn't take long before he found
one so if you look at emerging markets
about
95 percent of transactions are done in
cash
and this is very unsafe merchants
who are selling have to create a variety
of processes within their stores
to prevent pilferage from their staff
when you're traveling with a lot of cash
you can face theft
and then for the economies it costs
somewhere between five to seven percent
of gdp to clean
process all of that cash in nigeria
and in really most emerging markets the
reason why cash is still king
is first and foremost poor banking
infrastructure
so while nigeria has 23 banks
they only combined have about 5 000 bank
branches
so they don't have the reach to the mass
market so it's not that people don't
save they just do so through very
informal means
if you go to someone who is selling in a
in the market they are saving at what's
called a savings collector
so the savings collector is someone who
basically allows you to save money on a
daily basis with them
sometimes you don't get any interest on
your money when people do this and
people save also underneath their
mattress and their house and different
park places
they put money and so for me looking at
that i was like wow this is a huge
problem
there's got to be a better way to pay
than me having to pay
cash but ovosu
noticed something else i have a phone
and i have a phone signal and in fact i
have multiple phones
right because most nigerians carry two
to three phones and if i don't have a
phone signal on one network i have a
phone signal another network
so why can't i pay with my phone and
that's really what got me going
right and then i soon quickly realized
that the problem i
had was actually worse for most people i
was banked with two banks
but most people would not have been
banked at all so 61
of nigerians are not banked so i was
like wow
this problem is huge
so oviosu formed a startup called paga
which would allow nigerians to make
transactions with their phones
among other services but one of the
challenges was to convince a
cash-dependent customer that paying with
paga
was legitimate it was very clear to me
that for us to reach the mass market
we had to build a network of
what we call agents these are mom and
pops
pharmacies grocery stores people in the
local community
that are trusted the agents provided
consumers locations where paga was
supported
while offering the agents a commission
on transactions
so we had to door to door build out this
distribution network
and we now have 26 000 agents we have 16
million users on our platform last year
we did about two billion dollars in
transaction values
processed on our platform and pagas
services have evolved quite a bit since
it started in 2009.
with paga you can send money to anyone
in nigeria using their mobile phone
number
you can pay any utility bill
you can send money to any bank in
nigeria instant
real-time credit in the bank account you
can't withdraw money from any bank
we've actually frogged some of the
things that uh you know are not
available in the west
now there have been other successful
mobile payment services on the african
continent
like m-pesa a kenyan company with a
footprint in parts of east africa and
the middle east
but oviosu sees paga as a platform with
potential beyond other mobile payment
services
today already we allow you to trade and
buy
stock on our platform and you could
invest in treasury bills
and mutual funds things like that right
and all of that is from a third-party
provider
who is leveraging the open apis that we
have we have we have built
and so for us it's great because we
don't want to become an asset manager
but we are happy to partner with asset
managers to offer their services
uh on our platform while paga will
continue investing in local markets
they're planning to expand beyond
nigeria mexico is our next market
and it's actually amazingly similar to
nigeria
i feel like the mexican people are just
nigerians like we're just
very very similar family-oriented the
savings collector like i described
before
and use cash same way this is the 15th
largest economy in the world
uh but 90 of mexicans don't even save at
a formal financial institution
we're also launching um in ethiopia
where we actually already have a team of
about 60 people
that's a longer runway game we're
playing the long game there ethiopia is
the second largest
by population country in africa
so we are making real good headway
in terms of solving the problem for
payments and access to financial
services
to the mass market